[Music]
Walking Dead fans and I've met them when
I've gone to comic-con they are very
very serious about the show super
serious about the show
and they can get obsessive about the
show you went on a walking dead cruise a
cruise with you and some of the cast
went on a cruise so it's a whole ship
it's packed with Walking Dead fans that
must have been insane like that you
there's nowhere to go if it starts to
get to be too much unless they call in a
helicopter what was that like it was
great actually I mean you saw the fans
at certain moments you weren't around
them all the time which was you know but
it was fun being around them like we had
a really good time we did we like they
were also having it there you say is
there an average age for the fan or can
they get pretty young oh my goodness
three year olds three year olds who
won't worry you're right yeah who
watched the show I had a little four
year old I was holding she was telling
me about how she loved the sword and
what I did with it nothing yeah I was
scared of the show till I was in my 30s
I mean see she's four and she's saying I
love it when you chop zombies heads off
what's insane The Walking Dead it's kind
of turned into the new Family Ties you
know I mean everybody says they even
change the theme song folks tell me all
the time like we watch it together that
is our Sunday night family ritual I
think that's awesome I mean you know
that's our new family size the 21st
century I'll go with it I know that's
that says something incredible about
where we're headed here we go do you
meet many fans with Michonne tattoos
right I've met a few yes and some have
been like just texted to me like one of
the first time I saw it was the
wonderful man Vincent who does my hair
on the show he had a friend who's a
tattoo artist and said look what I just
finished doing and it was a gentleman's
calf and it was covered with my face and
I was a little surprised yeah and it's
also that can probably feel a little
intimidating almost when people say look
I had your image put on my body and this
has happened to you a lot right it has
it has there was a lady who had had me
all across her back and
you know there's been arms and some lady
there's a wonderful lady I saw her twice
actually and she had a sign her arm in
four places four of us and then she went
and had those signatures tattooed in I
said show changes for you like what if
you don't like it anymore and she said
no it's not gonna happen she showed me
all of her Lord of the Ring tattoos that
I still love them I bet you there's some
tattoos she didn't show you here's my
spin-doctors tattoo
you